sometimes you open your eyes and reality
feels like a dream you don't know what
is real what is fantasy what is actually
true and what is gaol fully fabricated
we're voyagers in an impressive but
unpredictable Armada that sails towards
the unknown an unknown that is quite
inviting but also quite perilous you
think that are supposedly stable
monolithic institutions have everything
under control
but they eventually crumble in the face
of a virus black swans like the corona
virus pandemic are inevitable because
they are a byproduct of our growth
mechanisms we think that our voyage is
smooth but it actually resembles
something more like a Mad Max narrative
the precarious times that we created are
here to stay and we sometimes reduce
ourselves to mere observers of an
inevitable future during such times the
collective shadow grows bigger and it
exposes us to our own fragility we
thought we were gods and we got
ferociously devoured by our own vanity
we reduced ourselves to primitive
instincts and we realized that the road
to theosis is no bed of roses
we cannot shy away from this truth not
only because of our fragile makeup but
also because of the inevitability of our
vision to align with the demands of the
cosmos reality is unknowable forever
hidden behind the veil of our
assumptions preconceptions definitions
and paradigms our leaders really try
hard to do the best for us but
inevitably get lost in the translation
of what is actually the best for us
some people are pessimists and some
people are optimists in the end nobody
really knows what the future will bring
we are surrounded by so many promises
and so much hot air that we are tired to
even deal with all this in the first
place we're last in the mishmash of
megalomania ambition and greed all these
are just projections projections of a
lack of honesty towards the real issues
that we're actually facing young said
quite elegantly about projections the
following the effect of projection is to
isolate the subject from his environment
since instead of a real relation to it
there is now only an illusory one
projections change the world into the
replica of one's own unknown face in
this video I will present five ideas
that we can entwine with our experience
in order to mentally equip ourselves
better for the future
we humans are greatly perturbed by fear
anxiety and uncertainty and in seeking
to become our existential angst
we sometimes anchor ourselves to
irrational and ignorant practices that
offer certitude and stability the
unprecedented evolution of technology
led to the expansion of our growth
practices in every level of our social
Asha loans we accelerated the entropy
and increase the level of complexity in
our systems to the extent that were
unable to control them we're actually
running faster than we can chasing
something abstract and incomprehensible
yes we want the perpetual betterment of
our species yes we want to eradicate
hunger and poverty yes we want to
minimize inequality yes we want to
achieve self transcendence but we need
to take into account that we are not
omniscient beings with benevolent
mindsets we're still greedy we're still
hungry for power we're still
psychologically ill we're still
unspiritual we're still humans if there
is one thing that we learn from
evolution is that evolutionary changes
take a lot of time we want to hike
evolution and transcend human nature as
fast as possible but most probably this
will backfire we don't necessarily need
to race that fast
our journey could resemble something
like a smooth ride through a mouth the
coast with the well preserved
convertible instead we choose to ride
mad Max's interceptor constantly
tweaking it and pumping it so it can
maintain us on the desert road for as
long as possible
panic is the first automatic human
response then comes acceptance then
comes adaptation then comes caring when
we face danger our brain switches to
panic mode and we become even more
irrational than we already are but why
can't we escape this mental prison this
question lies in the periphery of one's
consciousness we live aimlessly breathe
mechanically and act in the surging flux
of the present tense we forget to
breathe properly and act as rational
agents instead of primitive video
maniacs we can adapt to new realities
faster and better than we can actually
expect if we take a step back and look
at the bigger picture
panic should act only as an alarming
mechanism not as a survival mechanism
survival comes through cooperation and
caring not through panicking and despair
Carl Sagan once wrote in the course of
looking deeply within ourselves we made
silenced notions that give comfort
before the terrors of the world let us
sell these notions now let's move to
caring a bit faster than usual we are in
this together and we will overcome it
together
capitalism prevailed after the Cold War
and for good reasons it is a system that
attempts to orchestrate financial
freedom that is predicated on the
responsibility and ambition of its
individual in theory this sounds great
but in practice there are some caveats
to consider equality of opportunity is
indeed a freedom that we ought to
celebrate however we need to also
realize that opportunity has different
levels depending on social conditions
the conditions in poor ecosystems are
clearly less favorable than this
enriched ecosystems regardless of the
genetic makeup of the individual this
clear handicap creates all sorts of
problems especially in highly populated
areas where the competition in the
workplace and in the resource
acquisition is high so inequality
becomes the norm in capitalism and it is
this inequality that creates issues like
the corona virus or a myriad of other
misfortunes that were constantly facing
capitalism is not a panacea
the system inspired by our own nature
and this is a sad part of the equation
we think that capitalism is the best
system because we refuse to accept that
our nature could be flawed we all exist
in this bubble of egocentrism
where we think that we are so special
and disregard that our lack of humility
might be the source of the calamities we
actually experience we need to create
refuges of beneficial order that deny
the idea of constant antagonism and
embrace the idea of synergy despite the
issues that our differences beget the
keys to open our minds to further
possibilities and refuse the pseudo
comfort of passivity dystopian exists
everywhere and nowhere they are fed by
our demons and are projected outward as
physical creations that reflect the
colour of our inner world by 2030
depression will be the number one cause
of illness worldwide dystopias are
essentially a manifestation of our
depression if you walk in a city
regardless of where you are in the world
you will notice signs of both heat
opiates and dystopias whereas dystopian
has one meaning but place utopia can
mean both good place and no place in
other words utopia can be something
ideal and reachable but it can also be
something unattainable and non-existent
like a far-fetched dream so what happens
here is a wordplay in the perception
play languages uses a way to interpret
the world and because this
interpretation is multifarious we play
with words in order to ensure the
plurality of present and future
possibilities in any case dystopia sand
utopias constitute points of view even
in the most idyllic place humans can
find reasons to complain even in the
midst of chaos humans can maintain
stillness and peace of mind the fact is
that entropy will keep increasing and we
need to be constantly aware of this the
more entropy increases the more we lose
track of what is going on at a macro
level that is a sign that we need to
bring ourselves back to our own level of
influence
the fear of death is a paradox it is not
so much about the fear of death itself
for it is a state of nothingness which
as far as we know has no connection to
our current state of being it is more
about fear of the unknown which is a
perpetual happenstance throughout life
and it is this perpetuity that creates
states like existential angst and
general anxiety disorders anxiety is
disturbing because it is free-floating
it is not like fear fear is quite
specific specificity can be tackled
because we narrow our focus to something
that is within our scope of
understanding anxiety emerges from the
unquenchable thirst various individuated
human life along with the unremitting
oscillation between pain and boredom
memento mori is inescapable but it can
also lead to the emancipation of the
spirit slow the mind down because the
fear is about projections of future
events narrow your perception to a
singular point of focus a singular point
of focus that is now I don't try to play
guru I'm just a thinking person that is
puzzled every day by the absurdity of
existence I'm not any different than all
the people who worry or panic but I'm
aware of it and I try to reduce my
reactions to something that is
meaningful and well examined I take a
deep breath step back assume observer
state be grateful look inward and feel
humbled by the Oh inspiring vastness of
the human experience in situations of
chaos you can be a hero or you can be a
victim the choice is always yours hey
guys hope you enjoyed this video if you
did make sure to LIKE subscribe turn on
notifications and comment below
something cool please so that more
people can discover it if you want to
watch more videos from my channel check
out this one and this one take care see
you soon a turnout